very very deep neural networks are
difficult to train because of vanishing
and exploding gradients types of
problems in this video you learn about
skip connections which allows you to
take the activation from one layer and
suddenly feed it to another layer even
much deeper in the neural network and
using that you really build business
which enables you to Train very very
deep in that service sometimes even net
worth of over a hundred layers let's
take a look
rest nets are built out of something
called a residual block let's first
describe what that is here are two
layers of a neural network where you
start off with some activation and there
L then you go to a L plus 1 and then the
activation two layers later is a L plus
two so to go through the steps in this
computation you have a L and then the
first thing you do is you apply this
linear operator to it which is governed
by this equation
to go from a L to compute Z L plus one
by multiplying by the weight matrix and
adding that bias vector after that you
apply the relu the linearity to get a o
plus one and that's governed by this
equation where a L plus one is G of ZL
plus 1 then in the next layer you apply
this linear step again so it's governed
by that equation right so this is quite
similar to this equation we saw on the
left and then finally you apply another
relu operation which is now governed by
that equation where g here would be the
relu non-linearity and this gives you
you know a L plus 2 so in other words
for information from al to flow to al
plus 2 it needs to go through all of
these steps which I'm going to call the
main
of this set of layers in a position that
we're going to make a change to this
we're gonna take Al and just fast
forward it copy it much further into the
neural network to here and just add al
before applying the non-linearity they
really non-linearity and I'm gonna call
this the shortcut so rather than needing
to follow the main path the information
from Al can now follow a shortcut to go
much deeper into the neural network and
what that means is that this last
equation goes away and we instead have
that the output al plus 2 is the rather
non-linearity G applied to ZL plus 2 as
before but now plus al so the addition
of this al here it makes this a residual
block and in pictures you can also
modify this picture on top by drawing
this if your shortcut to go here I'm
going to draw it as going into this
second layer here because the shortcut
is actually added before the relative
non-linearity so each of these nodes
here where that applies a linear
function and a value so al was being
injected
after the linear part but before the
rather part and sometimes instead of the
terms shortcut you also hear the term
skip connection and that refers to Al
just skipping over a layer or kind of
skipping over almost two layers in order
to pass this information deeper into the
neural network so what the inventors of
ResNet so that would be climbing her
Sally Jiang shouting Ren and Jenson what
they found was that using residual
blocks
allows you to train much deeper neural
networks and the way you build a
resident is by taking many of these
residual blocks blocks like these and
stacking them together to form a deep
network so let's look at this network
this is not a residual network um this
is called as a
playing that's work this is a
terminology of the resonant paper to
turn this into residence what you do is
you add all those skip connections
although those short circuit connections
like so so every two layers ends up with
that additional change that we saw on
their previous slide to turn each of
these into a residual block so this
picture shows five residual blocks stack
together and this is a residual Network
and it turns out that if you use you
know a standard optimization algorithm
such as gradient descents or one of the
fancier optimization algorithms to train
a plane network so without all the extra
residual without all the extra shortcuts
or skipped connections I just drew in
and perkily you find that as you
increase the number of layers the
training error will tend to decrease
after a while but then they'll tend to
go back up and in theory as you make a
new network deeper you know it should
only do better and better on the
training set right so the theory in
theory having a deeper network should
only hope
but in practice on reality having a play
network so now the ResNet but having
play network this very deep means that
your optimization algorithm just as much
harder time in training and so in
reality your training error gets worse
if you pick a network that's too deep
but what happens with res Nets is that
even as a number of layers gets deeper
you can have the performance of the
trading ever to keep on going down you
know even retrain a network with over a
hundred layers and then now some people
experimenting with networks there are
over a thousand layers
although I don't see that use much in
practice yet but by taking these
activations being XOR these intermediate
activations and allowing it to go much
deeper than your network this really
hosts with the vanishing and exploding
gradient problems and allows you to
Train much deeper neural networks
without really appreciable loss in
performance and maybe at some point this
will Plateau this will flatten out and
doesn't help that much the deeper and
deeper networks but residents are so
even effective that helping train very
deep networks so you've now gotten an
overview of how resonance work and in
fact in this week's program exercise you
get to implement these ideas and see it
work for yourself
but next I want to share of you better
intuition or even more intuition about
why resinous work so well let's go onto
the next video